JEFFREY MARLOW:
As a scientist, we often go to
some of the most extreme
places on our planet,
to collect microbes,
bring 'em back,
understand what they're
doing and how they work.
These types of
organisms can actually
broaden our search
for life beyond earth.
By knowing what
microbes are capable of,
we can think about other places
where this could be happening.
( applause )
A little over a year ago,
I found myself camping
on the side of an
active volcano.
I was there as the
chief scientist
of an expedition that went to
examine Vanuatu's Marum crater.
And it was unlike any other
camping experience I'd ever had.
Right outside your tent window,
there is constantly a plume
of toxic sulfur dioxide.
You had to go with a respirator
whenever you went outside.
It was also smart to
wear long sleeves.
There are tiny microscopic
basaltic needles
that would fall down upon you.
And when the rain was
water, it was acid,
had a pH of about two.
Despite all these hazards,
it actually turns out
that microbes can
survive in these places,
and we were there
to figure out why.
We were there for this,
this is the crater.
It's about a kilometer
across, 500 meters deep.
And at the very bottom of it,
in this pit of roiling lava,
is the world's most
active lava lake.
We needed to get samples
from the very bottom
to understand how
microbes can survive,
so we descended down the cliff,
went as close to the edge of
the lava lake as we dared.
All around us, lava was spewing,
sometimes going over
the top of our heads,
raining down upon us.
It wasn't a great place to
be for a very long time.
But we were there
just long enough
to get our critical samples.
This is a place where
the earth is forming.
This is how rocks come to be.
They are formed by volcanoes.
And everywhere on the
surface of the planet,
microbes inhabit these rocks.
We wanted to see
how this started.
We collected samples
that were 30 seconds old.
We saw them pop up,
they were glowing red,
they finally cooled
off, we picked 'em up.
And we got a full
time series across
days, weeks, months,
years, across the island,
to figure out when microbes
colonized these rocks,
what that means in
terms of a longer term
succession of microbial
community inside these rocks,
and how that influences
elemental cycles on our planet.
So, volcanoes are
enormous, planetary scale,
loud, very obvious features.
But they actually created
these tiny micro-niches
that allow for distinct
forms of life to exist.
And as a geobiologist, my
interest is in these interfaces.
It's kind of where these
planetary scale processes
meet on the micro scale.
Places like this have been
found all over the world.
And microbes typically
find a way to survive.
There are organisms in the Rio
Tinto in southwestern Spain,
that can breathe metal
and create these acidic
pools of blood-red water.
The minerals that
are formed here
are actually found
on Mars as well.
Recently off the coast of Japan,
two and a half kilometers deep,
below the surface of the ocean,
there are
methane-producing microbes.
This is a whole different
class of organism.
These are the intra-terrestrials
living inside our planet.
And the lower
temperature limit of life
is still completely unknown.
Microbes can survive inside ice,
down to negative
20 degrees Celsius,
and probably even cooler.
When combined, these
forces really come together
to operate our planet.
We're on a microbial world.
Let's all just get used to it.
These microbes create more than
half of the oxygen
that we breathe.
They mobilize the
nutrients that supports
any sort of macroscopic life.
And on my quest to understand
what the limits of
this biology is,
I typically focus
on the deep sea.
We can think of the
earth as a battery.
In the sub-surface, in those
liquids and those gases,
those chemicals are
said to be reduced.
There are a lot of electrons.
On the very thin rind of the
planet that we operate in,
the atmosphere, the
surface world, the ocean,
that's said to be oxidized.
So where these places meet,
this pole and these
boundaries of the battery,
that's where energy
can be harvested.
So, the deep sea is
our best opportunity
to find new types of metabolism.
And there are sort of
three canonical categories
over the last few decades
that have been carved out
within this deep sea realm.
Black smoker hydrothermal vents
are precipitating
these metal sulfides,
several hundred degrees Celsius.
The Lost City
hydrothermal system
forms from water
rock interactions.
No magma needed.
And this creates
an alkaline system
that leads to a whole
different type of microbes.
And methane seeps.
These are places typically
where one tectonic plate
is subducting
beneath another one,
and the organic
goo that had kinda
fallen down on that first
plate is being broken down
and streaming up through
the earth's surface.
So, these methane seeps are
where I've done most of my work.
You can see the methane
bubbles coming out.
Not as exciting as black
smoker vents on TV perhaps,
but more important.
Because they're able to
turn that methane into rock,
might be the most important
thermoregulators on the planet.
Methane is an extremely
strong greenhouse gas,
so by soaking it up into this
rock, we can do a lot of good.
There are kinda those
three main flavors
of deep sea chemosynthetic
oases that I described,
but we're already sensing that
there are other flavors as well.
Recently in the
Mid-Cayman Trough,
the deepest and hottest
hydrothermal vent,
had ever been discovered.
And off the coast of Antarctica,
this carpet of yeti crabs
was found around
hydrothermal vents.
These crabs harvest
bacteria on their gills,
and eat those.
It's the microbes, though,
that are making
the food in the first place
from the chemicals in the vents.
Nonetheless, most of the deep
sea looks like this to us,
we have no idea what's going on.
( laughter )
That's because less than
0.01% of the deep sea
has ever been seen
by human eyes.
This is the equivalent
of Lewis and Clark
setting out on
their journey, 1804.
They leave their fort on the
banks of the Missouri River,
they walk about a half
mile to their canoes.
But instead of getting
in those canoes,
exploring the rest
of the continent,
seeing bison,
seeing Yellowstone,
encountering new cultures,
seeing the Rockies,
seeing a whole other ocean,
they spend the
rest of their lives
walking that half mile
and studying that.
So, why do we really
care about microbes?
What does it mean
to expand the realm
of metabolic possibility?
From a very
practical perspective,
we can do a lot of good.
The project I'm
working on right now
is taking these deep sea
methane-eating metabolism,
and trying to import it into
E. coli through genetic means
to turn methane into a bio-fuel.
The drugs and
biotechnologies of the future
will most likely come
from the deep sea,
or from the massive realm of
untapped genetic potential
in microbes around the world.
By understanding the vast realm
of possibility of microbiology,
we're also expanding the realm
of potentially habitable
worlds beyond our planet.
So other calculations that
our team had worked on
showed that the
methane-eating metabolism
we see in the deep sea
would have actually been
energetically possible on Mars
in the ancient past
when there was water.
But to me, most fundamentally,
this search is really
getting to the center
of what life is all about.
What is this crazy,
magical process
that moves electrons around,
and ends up creating
these self-sustaining,
self-replicating cells,
and ultimately leads to
civilization and culture?
There's so much more to get to,
and we're really just
starting this journey.
I can't wait to see
what we find. Thank you.
( applause )